[Music]
on this martin luther king jr day we
take a moment to remember the civil
rights icon and the legacy he leaves
behind good afternoon thanks so much for
joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce and
i'm christian gas that is clark county
marking the moment with its 39th annual
mlk day parade
now due to covet 19 the celebration of
dr king's legacy
was streamed online for more than four
hours viewers watched
taped and live segments with local bands
and performers
djs and elected officials this year's
theme was living the dream
the time to the time is right to do
what's right last year according to
organizers
more than 30 000 people attended the
parade in downtown las vegas
they also added that they have as many
people working the virtual event
as if as if it was physically held in
public
coming together is the message
we cannot affect change
as individuals only as a group only as
communities
and have to be like-minded about the
civil rights for all well this year's
parade is also teaming up with the
nevada help desk and tech queen
elite training institute who trained
certified and employed students looking
to get into the tech
industry about a dozen students ran the
event from
editing and video production to web
design pretty incredible